well pax is over time for my long
overdue summer movie season recap or at
least summary and as for this summer I
mean what can I say I mean what kind of
world do we live in with the two coolest
movies of the summer had to do with
talking toys and a group of people who
were all asleep great movies but I'm
just saying no I didn't see every movie
this summer I saw about 99% of the big
ones and what did we learn well we
learned that video game movies are still
crap shrek is burned out Megan Fox is
just as bad as you remember migraines
are only as common as the
post-production 3d crap that causes them
old school is a pretty safe bet for some
good entertainment Christopher Nolan is
still the king and it's normal for
adults to cry not saying it cried just
saying shut up dude there were my toys
I mean his toys not counting Vampires
Suck or the other vampires suck movie
I'd say the two worst movies of this
summer would have to be Jonah Hex and
probably last airbender now that I've
seen half the animation so I can see how
he totally butchered the characters yeah
it's got to be those two I would put
eclipse under that category but eclipse
is like a different thing altogether
categorizing Twilight with worst movies
of the year it's like categorizing
cancer with serial killers I mean yeah
both kill but with cancer it's it's like
no one's safe it's like there's no
stopping it top three best movies of the
summer inception Toy Story 3 and Mortal
Kombat rebirth
I'm not gonna like that's my pick for
number 3 how sad is that when a 7 minute
pitch videos cooler than most the crap
we've seen in theaters this summer
seriously so in the end the biggest
movie of this summer was Toy Story 3
broke a billion dollars proving that
most of us are not actually jaded pricks
and best movie it's kind of a matter of
opinion but I'm gonna say inception that
was the coolest movie this summer I
thought but there were so many winners
this summer it was a close race I mean
no one could have called that Toy Story
3 would have been the biggest an
inception would have been the best for
the biggest for me like I said Toy Story
3 but for the best the movie I'm looking
forward to the movie I think it's gonna
be the coolest I got to say inception
don't worry I'm not gonna say I told you
so
too modest I mean what happened to the
summer movie season I mean what can you
make with unlimited resources a massive
budget and countless workers well the
pyramids apparently and 3d converted
crap worth of all the good movies gone
and apparently the whole time
Christopher Nolan's going yeah don't
worry you studio dog hack bastards I got
this
pricks I mean when I was at PAX I was
playing the Force Unleashed 2 and it
felt like everything a cool movie should
feel like I had cool characters a good
story badassery great cinematography
I mean Hollywood videogames are stomping
you what the hell so we got a couple of
holiday movies that might help make up
for summer like Harry Potter and Tron
Legacy but in the end damage done and
two people who are concerned that I was
gonna stop doing movie reviews and
switch to game reviews that's not the
case I'll keep the movie reviews coming
I'll keep the the vlogs coming I'll just
also try to throw some video game
awesomeness in the mix it's all about
entertainment and I posted an article on
schmoes no calm talking about video
games and movies and how video games are
more cinematic and movies are more like
this last summer you can find a link
below check it out comment down there
let us know what you think so of the
summer movies what was your favorite
what was your least favorite what was
your most hated comment below blow that
[ __ ] up and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more